so what's your intuition
with cardano having the proof of stake
and then eventually smart contracts
versus
the bitcoin with layer 2 technologies
this kind of
evolving creature again you said you
can't really predict the future but
what's your intuition why one might be
uh
more successful than the other so the
problem with bitcoin is
it it is so slow it's like the mainframe
programming of
of the past and it's the only reason
it's still around is because there was
so much invested in keeping it around
that and we just kind of have to leave
it there and
one day cobalt will die you know it's
it's a
it's it's there's nothing about it from
a collection of usps that's particularly
desirable
you have extremely long settlement time
you have extremely low programmability
it is not aware of any other system
there's no native way of issuing an
asset in that system you can't even do a
pull transaction
i mean you can't do anything that's
interesting or unique there
and yeah all due respect it's you know
mafia all due respect you got some
problems
you come to me on the day of my
daughter's wedding i know i know so you
know all due respect to the bitcoin
people it's like an amazing
uh incredible first generation thing and
it really
we're all here because of bitcoin but
the problem is you have to upgrade the
damn thing
you know just because you were a high
school football star doesn't mean
that 30 years later you're still a high
school football star in the same shape
you got the beer belly you're old you're
not doing this thing again that's what
bitcoin has to do
there's fundamental improvements that i
think bitcoin can make
at the protocol level that would
actually make it an incredibly
competitive system like if they wanted
to keep nakamoto consensus proof of work
there's ways to enhance proof of work
i mean concierge did this with bitcoin
ng promoto veswanas did this with
uh prism make it ten thousand times
faster and you don't compromise the
fundamental security assumptions that
the system has
you can add programmability to it block
stream created a language called
simplicity
so there's there's actual ways to extend
and we did this with cardona with the
extended utxo model there's ways to
extend
what bitcoin has keep the philosophy the
accounting the way of thinking about
transactions but then suddenly you can
now do defy and other things
but what they've done is said we will
not evolve the base layer at all
and we're just gonna build all this
layer two stuff which is usually
highly fragile and centralized and
requires enormous effort at the base
level to do anything
there's it's not a coincidence vitalik
started as a color coins guy
and a master coin guy hanging out in
those circles he was trying to innovate
and do things in bitcoin and it was so
hard and difficult that he started
diverging and going and doing things
in a different system entirely uh you
know i knew the master coin guys jr only
all these people
they were maximalist they really wanted
to build something cool and exciting for
bitcoin
and anything they did the developers
would attack them it's oh you're you're
misusing op return you're doing this
that it was a holy war anytime you
wanted to evolve
so i think it's its own worst enemy it
has the network effect it has the brand
name it has the regulatory approval
but there's no way to change the system
even correcting obvious downsides in
that system
now what's really cool is ethereum
doesn't suffer from that problem
it is it's getting to a point where it
has a similar network effect to bitcoin
but the community there is
is completely different in culture they
love evolving they love upgrading
sometimes a little too much
uh and so that means that if you look at
the trajectory of things if i had to bet
just those two
systems bitcoin or ethereum i would say
nine times out of ten
ethereum is going to win the fight
against bitcoin if it was the only
competitor
but obviously we're here and a lot of
other people are here so there's
different things going on so it's a much
more complex game but you i think that's
always the key
you know zooming out a little bit you
know set the technology aside and the
word salad of cryptography aside because
it's too much
we have to always do is say what
incentive does the system have to evolve
and when you look at things like android
and the app store and these
analogous platforms you say ah the
evolution is user driven and there's a
financial incentive for the user to
participate
so if i had to look at the trajectory of
this thing come back 10 years later
it's probably going to have millions of
applications and lots of stuff going on
because that's the way the system was
constructed okay it makes sense
when you look at bitcoin you say what is
the incentive to evolve the system
there's none what is the incentive for
the system
to to get more competitive not in fact
it's the opposite they've turned it into
a religion
i i was in miami at this this bitcoin
conference there i had a
toilet paper roll thrown at me that had
[ __ ] coin written on it
you have max kaiser out on the stage you
know doing his best um
rick james impression you know was he
the guy that did the f elon
yes yes you know and so you're watching
this stuff and you say okay first why
would anybody want to join that
and then second where is the
conversation about
how do we achieve something i started
with cardano the end in mind i said look
you know we really want to sit down
and build this financial operating
system and the definition of success is
the poorest person in the world has
access the same system as the richest
person
in the world and they both get treated
fairly we've never had that happen
before
okay that's something you can agree with
it disagrees say it's boiling the ocean
it's impossible
at least i have something i can't for
the life of me understand what the hell
is the point of bitcoin
when i joined the bitcoin space way back
in the day
it was hey we hate the dollar and you
know hey we like gold a lot let's create
digital gold let's build a payment
system
and then it just kind of went all these
different directions and nobody can
actually tell you what bitcoin is for
it's a store of value okay you know if
there's some proof of work
thing where maybe you're like
incentivizing that alternative energy to
be pretty i don't know it's like
nobody really knows the philosophy
there's no direction and they say but
don't worry
just buy and hold and everything will
sort its way out
i believe it's huddle yeah huddle what
about the idea of digital gold
so trying to replace that particular
physical material that is gold
transferring to the digital something
okay let's do that then
and just say that's all it does then why
are we doing lightning why are we doing
any of these other things
you don't really need with you know a
commodity a digital commodity
high throughput you can have slow
settlement you can have high transaction
fees all these types of things and
and you know that's that's fine okay
it's that's something pick it
well the idea is to to try to come up
with technology like the lightning
network
that could have something like gold but
then still build an economy around it
something with a high throughput
transaction and have we ever built a
successful banking credit system off of
cold
never it never works because there's too
much volatility
underlying asset would you take a gold
denominated loan for something if
somebody says all right i'll give you
five bars of gold to go buy this car
and pay me back five and a half bars of
gold nobody would know in five years
where they come out in that kind of
arrangement
the idea is that the gold is used for
the settlement of transactions and then
you're operating
the actual economies operating outside
of gold
and then you kind of connect back to
gold go back to the gold reserve and we
tried that for a long time
it didn't really work in a modern global
economy we had the brentwood's agreement
all these other things and
and so i understand what you're saying
and maybe maybe there's some merit to
that but if that was
really in earnest where they want to go
then the conversation should be about
well how do we make it easy for layer
two protocols to interact with bitcoin
so why is simplicity not built into it
why is it taking so long to do snore
sigs why is it taking so long to do all
these obvious upgrades
which are cryptographically low danger
also nipa pals
non-interactive proofs of proof of work
there's no cost to doing that it's just
a property of proof of work where
certain puzzles are more special than
other puzzles and by noticing that you
can create these beautiful proofs
that allow you to have side chains and
like clients it's not
compromising security of the system it's
just something you get for free with
proof of work
those came out in 2016. there's
derivative work fly client floating
around where the hell is it
yeah this is the frustration that i have
is like if you really are serious about
this whole lightning and gold economy
thing
i love choice i'm a libertarian by
nature i love competition
and you know i read all those books i
read louie von mises work and murray
rothbard's work working
i love what hayek had to say about
private currencies let's go try it
that's great but then you have to have
some focus and commitment as an
ecosystem and the excuse they use is
well no we don't because we're
decentralized and then and because we're
decentralized we don't need that
as if there's some sort of guiding swarm
intelligence that will
naturally push the system in that
particular interaction
but then you ask well how do people
measure the success of bitcoin
is it the fact that they've actually
achieved lots of
transactions and lots of actual economic
activity and lots of businesses
accepting people go up
it's the price that's what they do that
and that's the only thing they pay
attention that's why this is the most
attended bitcoin conference in history
not because somehow bitcoin got so much
more adoption it's because this is
the highest price point bitcoin has ever
been this year you know over 30 000. so
first of all let me state that charles
for the most
part is purely objective the uh the bias
that comes in
for the record i want to say that i have
heard because you mentioned the mafia
that you prefer good fellows over the
godfather
so a man who prefers good fellows over
godfather you take it for that opinion
for what it is
uh i actually had to think about that
one for quite a bit
i think oh come on joe pesci was so good
he's incredible
i i also love casino and those big
glasses on de niro i love it
with sharon stone but we could talk
about that for hours
you